the battle to clear Isis from its last
stronghold in Syria entered a critical
new phase this morning for more than two
months Charlie d'Agata has been
reporting from the frontlines in eastern
Syria and that's where us-backed forces
are making what they hope to be the
final move against Isis Charlie went to
see the fight under cover of darkness
and he sent us this report from bagus
Syria where a shrinking group of Isis
fighters is trying to hold on
after weeks of fighting in what has
become a virtual stalemate we got word
this morning from the Syrian democratic
forces we can confirm they have entered
that last Isis camp but they cautioned
that fighting is still going on and
certainly as of last night the battle
was raging moonlight alone lit the way
as us back Syrian soldiers gave us a
close-up view of what's left of Isis
we're just on the edge of the front line
and these are sniper positions looking
down into the goose where Isis is
fighting back
sounds of both coalition fighter jets an
incoming gunfire filled the air we've
been told to stay low because just on
the other side of that Ridge is an Isis
position and as soon as we got here we
heard bullets whizzing overhead for
weeks American and coalition airstrikes
had pummeled a tiny slice of land not
more than a few hundred yards wide it's
hard to imagine how anybody can survive
yet by day they emerged to battle
America's allies on the ground here
soldiers of the Syrian democratic forces
some look like teenagers augury kobani
told us they were taking aim at a group
of Isis fighters trying to hide behind
trees are you surprised they're still
fighting it's still going on he said but
there's progress every day but progress
is slow and while the so-called
Caliphate is now little more than a
junkyard heaped with wrecked cars
hardcore Isis holdouts have managed to
defend it against every
in America and its allies have been able
to unleash for months now nobody here is
celebrating yet and there were
airstrikes over night we heard gun
battles this morning but the
announcement from the Syrian democratic
forces that their soldiers have now
entered that last Isis camp may be a
significant step forward for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata in bogus eastern
Syria we all hope that's true thank you
Charlie